you
I have blamed the perception of art
being liberal on Picasso because he was
a card-carrying communist it's
interesting the artist who painted the
great anti-fascist picture saw
absolutely nothing wrong with
totalitarian communism and certainly
most artists tend to be liberal I don't
think though that that means that
Republicans or conservatives can't
appreciate art and that also that there
aren't artists who can be conservative
that that might be the sort of tendency
but I don't think it's it's exclusive
and I also think art particularly the
kind of art that's in David's sling is a
real uniting force I mean I don't care
if you are Bernie Sanders or Ted Cruz I
think you both can come together to
appreciate an achievement like
Michelangelo's David that shouldn't be a
difficult or divisive thing it should be
a uniting thing whether we want to be or
not we are engaged in a civilizational
struggle with forces that are extremely
hostile to what we would consider to be
the Western tradition although now it is
a global tradition on with the inclusion
of states like Japan in Israel this is
something we should all come together to
support and celebrate and so art can
that be I think of wonderful vehicle for
that kind of unity
you